hey guys it's justine and today is a
little bit different of a video
you guys all know rosanna she does
really fun baking videos lifestyle
videos here on youtube and we have done
a ton of collabs together
but today is a collab like no other
today
row is going to be me for the day and
i'm going to be her for the day
this is going to be so much fun but
first a huge thank you to ogx for
sponsoring this video
this is kind of wild because this is
actually the shampoo that i have been
using
for years like this is what i use every
single day ro and i have a lot of
differences but the one thing that we do
have in common is our hair care routine
we've actually bonded over the types of
products that we use
the one thing that we cannot live
without is dry shampoo
what i love so much about ogx is they
have tons of different scents but also
different types of shampoos and
conditioners for different types of hair
so here's a view that i have in my
current collection
extra volume extra strength check
hydrating plus
tea tree mint i love mint extra strength
hydrating repair
check oh did you think that you needed a
little hair mask for some extra strength
and restoration
check i actually use this all the time
on the ends of my hair they also even
have some body wash
i love that all of their products are
paraben and sulfate free that's
something that i always look for any
type of hair care or body wash
so thank you ogx for checking that off
my list
i wish you guys could smell it i guess
you can if you go to your local retailer
where you normally would buy shampoo and
conditioner
look for it let me know what your
favorite is shout out to our girl candy
ever since she launched this this is the
mermaid dust by ogx
it smells good it smells like a hawaiian
vacation
i need to finish getting ready and then
i need to head to rosehouse
to become her wish me luck
[Music]
i feel like i love clean hair
i also like the feeling of the dry
shampoo in it ogx makes it super easy to
get salon quality hair
at home and now i think i'm ready to go
biro
but is ro ready for me to be here
oh my gosh hello hello okay so i'm here
and i'm gonna become you what is step
one we gotta make your look
look like ro yeah you do your part here
we gotta bring it to the sit gotta give
you a center part we'll get some weight
what you'll see
hair and makeup is waiting for you
upstairs this is your first workout
oh wow booty okay this
[Music]
makeup artist the best and here's your
glam chair
all right beauty queen get in that chair
one of the things that i was telling
them before i got here
is that we've bonded over using the same
hair products
yes oh my gosh this is so great for
years i was like oh my god justine has
great hair i wonder what she uses and
then it turns out
we use the same thing i know this is
this is my
favorite they also sent me one that i've
never tried before the tea tree and mint
have you tried that one
what it's so great i love mint oh you
also loved it as well
so you would probably already have to
try it so i'm gonna get the full
glam row treatment today yes you are
steam does her part
over on this side the left side and i do
a center part or a right side part i
hope
i don't want to do it i'm going to
become row now your hair always looks so
[Music]
perfect
i've got breakfast coming for you oh no
coffee we're going to be doing tea today
it might be a little hot so be careful
is it really hot no but it's like really
good little bit of honey a little bit
a little bit of mint so row how do you
feel about my transformation
i'm loving it so far just mean i'm
getting the vibe we've got the center
part we've got the wavy big
curls it's coming together you're
drinking my favorite
morning beverage other than coffee now
i've got
your row breakfast this is incredible
being row is cool
today i'm not gonna have you go to like
45 meetings and film a million videos
but we're gonna do some fun stuff it's a
paleo smoothie
you like it oh my gosh yes
[Music]
everything and the hair
is holding those curls girl it is i mean
i used to curl my hair like a long time
ago
yeah do you remember i saw some pictures
of your hair curly i went through like
oh i curl my hair now phase and then
i just got really lazy it takes a lot of
time
to do
[Music]
oh my gosh it looks so great oh thank
you so much oh my god i can't wait to go
see rose gosh
i am my makeup professionally done in
so long like i feel so cooled out
it's been great okay you know what i'm
digging it
me too this is so amazing step one
justine's got the row hair and glam
she's got the look
and now we're gonna start the day i have
two dogs
two frenchies oh whoa yeah oh yes wow
here they are here who's hungry there's
coconut and potato muffins
okay so let me show you how i feed them
okay i'm gonna have you do this part so
you're just gonna open the fridge
and there's a big plastic like a
tupperware eat right there
that's dog food it looks like yeah like
a casserole
i was gonna say this looks like a sweet
potato casserole that i like for
thanksgiving pretty much is a sweet
potato this is for your dogs
yeah it's all organic it's cooked in a
local kitchen
they cook all this organic food and they
work with a vet and they mix it all
together so i order these and they're
frozen
and then they're their newest pack i
found them and i put them in here
so do you think that maybe i can have
some of this
it has sweet potato no way yeah start
with a couple scoops in each bowl
yeah big scoops one scoop perfect
and one more one more yeah we got a
growing puppy
that that much yeah how many times a day
do you feed them
three times a day okay we're gonna heat
them up in the microwave
you heat it up to 15 to 20 seconds
i'll do 17. okay perfect that's a great
temperature
i have the same microwave good girls
that's a good girl good girls
we're heating up your dinner oh yeah
this is how you do ready
yeah you know that dog
pitch switcher and they love it they're
like we know what that
is sometimes when i'm putting the bowl
down she will spin in a circle
you guys are very cute and sometimes
she'll give you a double
you ready time for dinner
okay come on let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go over here over here
here we go
oh we got it we got a spin we got two
spins
two spins good girl good girl okay
so fast she's our speed eater that's
ridiculous blueberry muffins a little
slower
that is the fastest i've ever seen a
doggy like that's insane
it's like a joke like she's like
trolling us like how fast
did she leave hey that's not hey you go
over there
good girl what do we do after this well
we gotta go
poop them now and then we work out i'm
red we just did glam though you work out
after a glam
sometimes that's how the day goes okay
i'm here for it i acknowledge and i know
and i understand
it's it's a whole thing okay come on
baby who wants to go potty
wait let's take a ball too here you go
let's go come on let's go inside
okay oh my gosh go buddy go buddy come
on we need a poo poo
let's go come on we need a poo poo
there's a potty there's a potty a poop
i have never had one of my friends pick
up my dog's poop i
almost feel bad but you're me for a day
i don't mind i mean i pick up my dog's
poo all the time this is
this is what i'm here to do okay yeah
just grab a hold of it you got it girl
papoose have been eliminated good job
you want to play ball show and then now
show her the ball she's so excited look
she's shaking
she loves this this is her favorite game
ready go get it go get it go get it
oh good that is so
[Music]
excitement
are you ready to go lift some weight i
am i didn't work out today yet so
this is good all right we gotta warm up
we got a little cardio warm up
guys come on back inside let's go get a
treat let's go get treat treats she's
like come here
come on there's still somebody out here
so that means
blue bear come on retreat
[Music]
oh my gosh jesse she does not want to
come and she wants to play ball there
you go oh gosh she almost bit my whole
hand off here i'll just put that inside
there
treat and then ball good girl good girls
i'm gonna wash my hands and let's work
out oh yeah here we go
i would really love to play a copy
written song now that they uh
you know goes something about rolling
and out rolling it out
yeah rolling out
[Music]
shoot your feet out oh my gosh keep your
hips up that is so deceiving
yes three nice job
five so oh great when ro came to my
house
i made her do jiu jitsu and now she is
beating me up with these
random strength exercises yeah i was
gonna have you jump right but you know
what we'll just do kettlebell swings and
collar
[Music]
man i need to come work out with you a
little more often
oh my god yeah that would be so fun you
could take me jogging
i'm not great at running but i could
just drive around like this you know
what if you get quarantined with the
treadmill you sure
uh learn a lot if that does it for the
workout we just gotta do it
two more times through oh i thought we
were done
we're not
[Applause]
woke up our done muscles and now we're
gonna go test some recipes
oh i love this it's gonna be fun we
worked out
we did glam we fed the dogs now it's
time to test
some recipes because you are a baker if
you guys forgot i'm ro
today so i'm a baker you're a baker i'm
a baker
because people have been loving when
you've been testing tick tock recipes
they're loving when i have been testing
that me i'm a baker i'm ro
we are gonna be testing soda pie
[Music]
in the freezer there's a pie crust okay
pre-made pie crust
in the freezer i think it's medium top
shell freezer medium somewhere
oh wow look at all this stuff in here
i'm gonna do a little shopping in my own
freezer that i have look at this
there's a lot of good things in there
could you get some butter butter is in
the fridge yeah we're gonna need to
unsalt it okay
unsalted extra creamy so how much butter
do we need do you think with the tik tok
recipe some of them don't have
measurements what kind of recipe is
that's not a recipe that's right
fraud right and some of them have
partial measurements
one cup of sugar let's do that first
yes that's nice yeah that's fine perfect
put in there that we gotta whisk
together here i'll grab me a whisk
okay i've done that are there a couple
pot oh there's two twice
oh we got two oh surprise
okay i'm actually gonna keep one of
these and make a little apple pie for my
mom
you mean my mom yeah yeah you're my
momma
i'm gonna make a pizza you're gonna make
an extra pie for your mom because
oven is preheating to 400 fahrenheit
perfect
so you're just going to pour in one can
of
lemon lime flavored soda
not just the pie just right in there
right in i just
i this is i don't think this is going to
work
scoop in the dry ingredients okay just
scoop it in the flour
and the sugar is going like don't mix
that's the trick
really in the video it said do not mix
it all and it's supposed to bubble and
fizzle like this it looks like a science
experiment
wow and then what do we do after this
add a little bit of vanilla extract i'm
a little sauce
this pie is sauce this is this is a
whole pie of sauce
oh yeah i just feel like okay well
there's like weird right
super weird something's definitely
happening oh this is gonna blow your
mind the last step
sprinkle grated butter put it all over
the pie
oh it looks like cheese it does
oh this is a first for me this is so
weird
there might be a piece of my finger in
there too i think
can't be too short it just makes it
better
yeah justine you're doing a great job
thank you i'm you
all right it's pretty good just be
careful
and you go little pie for 30 minutes 30
minutes
and then we have to reduce set a timer
for 30 minutes see you soon little
perfect messy pie i know all right we've
moved on
to a new activity with my mom is here
hi mom good to see you it's been so long
since i'm road today i don't cheat but
normally when i play board games or any
type of card games i will
look at everyone's cards so this is
great that we're separated
apple doesn't fall far from the tree i
guess over here
i'm gonna have a bite of pasta and then
let's get this game started this pasta
looks good
did i make this i made this i'm such a
great cook
you can either make it or we order it so
we've got all these things here
what do we do
the timer is done the first time or we
have to check it
looking like it's baking shut up really
oh yeah oh okay all right wow okay so
it's very liquidy it's so weird because
the top looks big but then it's like
totally moving around yeah it's like
it's very liquidy okay so we're gonna
put that back in there perfect 375.
set the timer for 30 more minutes
this one but what is this little
just hanging out here
oh my then you're done you won oh my god
this doesn't happen to me very often
that's amazing usually mom kicks my butt
all the time
this is so fun it's almost time i think
it's going to be a fail
because 30 minutes ago it was like a
liquid pie liquid does
bake out when it's you know at high heat
oh i know i know i know
maybe maybe it baked out that's boiling
i mean the top is crusted but then the
bottom is
just do we drink it let's let it cool
for just a few minutes
give it a chance to set up and then
we'll cut into it
maybe let that settle a little i don't
want to wait anymore
like we just need to know and i honestly
even if we leave this in here overnight
i just think the pie is gonna freeze
like it's liquid it's it's a mess
i was hopeful that it would set up oh my
gosh
thank you moving if we would have maybe
put more flour in or something i don't
know i mean a lot more things like
everything you'd put in a pie this is
rancid
oh this is just an absolute atrocious
mess
somebody is a liar oh my gosh let me get
us a fork
i'm gonna taste it i'm
i have disgusted here let me get a
little topping for you
this monstrosity this is recipe testing
is you you've gotta try it
oh it kind of tastes good tastes really
good
what the heck it tastes delicious oh my
gosh this is disgusting but also really
good
consistency and texture is terrible it's
more
soupy than pie why is it terrible
texture but it tastes amazing the
texture's disgusting it's slimy
but it tastes really good mess but it
tastes good
bro this was so much fun thank you so
much for letting me be you for a day
we also did a video over on ro's channel
i'll put a link in the description if
you want to check it out where ro
was me for a day there's tech there's
jiu jitsu
yes and a lot of other random things so
many things it was
awesome go check it out i had so much
fun and there was maddie
maddie that's my doggie
[Music]
thanks again to ogx for sponsoring this
video i can't wait to see what you guys
think of the video where ro becomes me
for a day